joining us now is jody cantor of the new
york times who is a cbs news contributor
her reporting on sexual abuse in the
workplace helped inspire the metoo
movement jody thank you so much for
joining us listen there's a headline in
the new york times it says this good
morning r kelly's conviction represents
a major metoo moment for black women but
boy did this take a very very long time
i talked to one of the survivors
yesterday that said finally justice has
been served can you talk about what this
actually means
this is the question everybody's asking
this morning my colleague troy claussen
who covered the trial wrote a story that
said the lingering question here is what
took so long given the overwhelming
amount of evidence presented
not only in this trial but in
documentaries and in reporting and
victim accounts that we have seen
for years
especially since listen this wasn't a
case of he said she said this was a case
of he said she said she said she said or
he said they said
what made it different this time do you
think
well i think that if you watch the way
this trial
was was laid out the amount of evidence
the number of accounts the varieties of
evidence that were presented were
overwhelming and compelling we're
talking about
audio that was played at the trial with
with graphic details that were so
disturbing that it's almost hard to
mention them on television we're talking
about first-hand accounts from victims
and we're also talking about this is one
of the metoo cases in which we're not
just looking at an individual
perpetrator we're looking at a system of
enablement in which women were silenced
again and again
i know jody i don't want that point to
get by that you just said the the
evidence that was in the case was so
vile so vulgar so despicable that the
judge didn't even want the public to
hear it i think that that says a lot
about what's what happened in this case
what message does this send to survivors
do you think
well i think what we see is that the
overwhelming power of the metoo movement
just continues to endure and even after
all of the obstacles even after a trial
a few years ago that did not result in a
conviction the
the
there is very little that is more
ultimately powerful
than these victims being willing to tell
their stories and they ultimately
prevailed you know i spoke to tarana
burke a few weeks ago about her new book
and what she said is
we
we have a problem in that we tend to see
the metoo movement as a tennis match
like when cuomo leaves office we say
okay you know one point for the women
for the victims when cosby gets freed we
say oh you know subtract one point from
the metoo movement and it's time to
even while that score keeping is
somewhat inevitable the bigger question
is you know what is me too making
possible and i think we see that in this
trial not only in the way the victims
ultimately prevailed but also in the
fact that there was kind of a new legal
theory that was used to bring this case
and you had a set of prosecutors who
seemed very determined to find a way to
see justice for the victims
all right jody cantor thank you so much
and he still has other cases pending we
thank you for your time this morning